BARTON ZWIEBACH: Do
normal wave analysis
to demonstrate that indeed these
things should not quite happen.
So for that, so ordinary waves
and Galilean transformations.
So when you have a wave,
as you've probably have
seen many times before,
the key object in the wave
is something called
the phaze of the wave.
Phaze, the phaze.
And it's controlled by this
quantity kx minus omega t.
k being the wave number, omega
being the angular frequency
and we spoke about.
And the wave may be sine of that
phaze or cosine of that phaze
or a linear combination of sines
and cosines, or E to this wave,
any of those things
could be your wave.
And whenever you have
such a wave, what we say
is that the phaze of this
wave is a Galilean invariant.
Invariant.
What it means is that two
people looking at this wave,
and they look at the
point on this wave,
both people will agree on
the value of the phaze,
because basically, the
reality of the wave
is based on the phaze, and if
you have, for example, cosine
of this phaze, the place
where this cosine is 0
is some of the phaze, and if
the cosine is 0, the wave is 0,
and everybody should agree that
the wave is 0 at that point.
So if you have a place where the
wave has a maximum or a place
where the wave is 0,
this is an ordinary wave,
everybody would agree that at
that place you have a maximum
and in that place you have a 0.
So observers should agree
on the value of this phaze.
It's going to be an invariant.
And we can rewrite this phaze
in a perhaps more familiar way
by factoring the k, and then
you have x minus omega over kt,
and this is 2 pi over
lambda, x minus--
this quantity is called
the velocity of the wave,
and we'll write it this way.
And I'll write in one last way--
2 pi x over lambda minus
2 pi V over lambda t.
And this quantity is omega
and this quantity is k.
So this is our phaze.
And we've said that it's
a Galilean invariant, so I
will say that S should see--
the observer S prime
should see the same phaze--
phaze-- as S. So phi prime,
the phaze that S prime sees,
must be equal to phi when
referring to the same point.
When referring to the same
point at the same time.
Let's write this.
So phi prime should
be equal to phi.
And phi, we've written there.
2 pi over lambda x minus Vt.
And this is so far
so good, but we
want to write it in
terms of quantities
that S prime measures.
So this x should
be replaced by 2 pi
over lambda x prime plus
Vt minus Vt like this.
And I could even
do more if I wish.
I could put t prime
here, because the t and t
primes are the same.
So phi prime, by the condition
that these phazes agree,
it's given by this,
which is by the relation
between the coordinates and
times of the two frames, just
this quantity.
So we can rewrite this as 2
pi over lambda x prime minus 2
pi over lambda V 1 minus little
v over capital V t prime.
I think I got the algebra right.
2 pi over lambda, the sine--
yes, I grouped those two
terms and rewrote in that way.
So that is the phaze.
And therefore, we
look at this phaze
and see, oh, whenever
we have a wave,
we can read the wave
number by looking
at the factor
multiplying x, and we
can read the
frequency by looking
at the factor multiplying t.
So you can do the same
thing in this case
and read, therefore,
that omega prime,
this whole quantity
is this, omega prime.
And this is k prime,
because they can
respond to the frame as prime.
So omega prime is
equal to this 2 pi
V over lambda, which
is omega, times 1
minus V over V. And
k prime is equal to k
or, what I wanted to show, that
lambda prime for a normal wave
is equal to lambda for ordinary
wave moving in the medium.
So at this moment, one
wonders, so what happened?
What have we learned?
Is that this wave function
is not like a sound wave.
It's not like a water wave.
We're doing everything
non-relativistic.
But still, we're
seeing that you're not
expected to have agreement.
That is, if somebody
looks at one wave function
and you look at the
same wave function,
these two people will not
agree on the value of the wave
function necessarily.
So the things that we conclude--
so the conclusions are
that waves are surprising.
So size are not
directly measurable--
measurable-- because if you had
a quantity for which you could
measure, like a sound
wave or a water wave,
and you could measure
aspects to it,
they should agree between
different observables.
So this is going to
be something that
is not directly measurable--
not all of psi can be measured.
Some of psi can be
measured, and you're already
heard the hints of that.
Because we said any
number that you multiply,
you cannot measure, and in
the phase that you multiply,
you cannot measure.
So complex numbers
can't be measured,
you measure real numbers.
So at the end of the day, these
are not directly measurable,
per se.
The second thing is that
they're not Galilean invariant,
and that sets the stage
to that problem 6.
You see, the fact
that this phaze that
controls these waves
is Galilean invariant
led you to the quality
of the wavelengths,
but these wavelengths
don't do that.
The de Broglie wavelengths
don't transform
as they would do for a
Galilean invariant wave.
Therefore, this thing is
not Galilean invariant,
and what does that mean?
That if you have
two people and you
ask, what is the value of the
wave function here at 103,
the two observers might give
you a different complex number
for the wave function.
They will just not agree.
Not all is lost,
because you will
find how their measurements
can be compared.
That will be the
task of the problem.
How-- if you have a wave
function, how does your friend,
that is moving
with some velocity,
measure the wave function?
What does this other
person measure?
So the end result, if you have
a point here at some time t,
the wave function
psi of x and t is not
going to be the same as
the wave function measured
by the prime
observer at x prime t
prime, so this point is the
point x and t or x prime and t
prime.
These are two different
labels for the same point.
You're talking about
the wave function
at the same point
at the same time.
You still don't agree.
These two people will not agree.
If they agreed,
this wave function
would have a simpler
transformation law
with a wavelength
that this can serve.
So by simply discussing
the Galilean properties
of this wave, we're led to know
that the de Broglie waves are
not like normal matter
waves that propagate
in a medium or simple.